Joe Jonas is it stripping down and
talking a porn for notion magazine okay
this is awesome Joe shows off his stuff
in a series of a sexy shots and inside
the issue he admits he got caught
watching porn as a teen yes back in his
Joe bro days joe says no one walked in
on him while he was a watching but there
was a dead giveaway in the mail quote I
would use my address to log into the web
sites for a week or two straight there
was a postcard with a naked woman on it
saying come join us again Joe or we
really miss you or you naughty boy come
visit us again Joe reminds us that his
dad was a pastor at the time oh yeah
this confession comes at just after Joe
opened up about losing his virginity to
ashley greene in a reddit AMA I think
life's too short you know I mean
ultimately I think of myself as an
honest guy and I think those are those
moments in your life where you have to
just be true to yourself and true to the
world you know I i I'm I'm not out to
like hurt anybody but I think ultimately
like I'm just telling my stories of what
I can say for my heart
you